oh I know this person I'm playing Santa
played Hikaru
this week it only gets tougher
there we go
uh it's um it's a bird
all right
I saw a bird earlier actually
I I have a friend with a pet bird
but I don't know if that's gonna help
this uh
this game
E4
okay
um
E6 might be coming at some point
wouldn't be too bad though
I'll start with this
now but then still G4
with E6 mind you have Queen H4
lineage for
there's also Knight H4
you gotta just play Knight H4
and then H5
that's slightly terrifying
to deal with it
I want the bishop on E7
I
probably no good
yeah I have to take twice
it's not pleasant
I don't do what I gotta do
not six move
it's so ugly though
you broke up fades
position so passive
the E6 Knight B6 and maybe I stay alive
here
I'm getting squeezed
like an orange
of this move
how do I even do anything
this move
maybe Rook G2
I Rook G2
or ideas I just want to attack
running mate
um
no it's a two
I think he blundered
we've eaten though
so he didn't
oh no his Queen but oh no my king
oh
ah nice combination
for a moment I thought that maybe he
missed my Bishop covers that Fades but
I miss the fact I just got needed
good game though
that's a cool one
yeah this guy was kind of good at chess
you should maybe play in tournaments
should I do game review let's let's see
uh let's see the estimated rating for
Magnus 93 accuracy
play the level of 33.50
that's better than like his actual
reading okay this is an overestimate
any brilliant moves
or a few great moves
bishopath 3 was a great move
wait I want to see with um engine
because I thought the opening was okay
I haven't really studied like so much
bird
ah F6
I've seen the structure before
my night kind of got sidelined
yeah he just like gradually outplayed me
like it's so hard to stop at five
I mean I was still holding on kind of
like it's not completely completely
losing
until certain things started happening
it was very gradual
[Music]
like even here I'm still alive
but then yeah after takes in D5 this was
rough
a bishop C1 only moved to win
Bishop D2 also keeps them Edge
yeah how about a move work f8 that's
such a Savage move
because the bishop or Rook can take it
but the prospect of E7 is kind of
painful for black
now do we consider this move a queen
sacrifice
or is a pawn sacrifice
because white briefly had a queen
that just left the board
wait Magnus withdrew he just wanted to
play me and that's that's his tournament
oh that's kind of
it's disappointing but at the same time
I'm happy I got I got to play him before
he actually withdrew yeah last time he
withdrew Midway through a tournament
there is a huge Scandal so
hopefully I'm not
involved in that this time